in the last video we made a visual
argument as to why the this expression
has to be less than one-third and this
expression we already figured out is the
fraction that are bears now i will make
an algebraic argument or i could call it
an analytic argument and to make this
argument i'm going to leave this
expression we know this is the fraction
that are bears and i'm going to write
this one-third in a form that looks a
lot like this and then based on the
information have we can directly compare
them so how can i write one-third maybe
with the b as a numerator
well one-third is the same thing as b
over three b which is the exact same
thing as b
over
b
plus b
plus b so now this is looking pretty
similar the only difference between this
expression right over here
b over c plus d plus b and b over b plus
b plus b is that our denominators are
different and the only difference in our
denominators this denominator has a c
plus d here while this has a b plus b
over here
now we have to ask ourselves a question
what is larger is c plus d
larger than b plus b and i encourage you
to pause that and think about that for a
second
well
yes we already see right over here it
was given to us that c is greater than d
that is greater than b so both c and d
are greater than b so c plus d is
definitely going to be greater than b
plus b so this denominator right over
here is greater so this has a larger
denominator
larger
larger denominator denominator this
right over here has a smaller
smaller
denominator
denominator and since we know this has a
larger denominator this has a smaller
denominator they have the exact same
numerator they both have b as the
numerator we know that this whole thing
we know that this whole thing must be a
smaller quantity
smaller
quantity if you have the same numerator
but one expression has a larger
denominator it must be smaller like wait
how does that work well just remember i
mean just imagine you have the same
numerator what's going to be bigger a
over 7 or
a
over 5.
well here you're dividing a by 7 you're
dividing into many more chunks and over
here so this right over here smaller
this right over here is larger so this
is the larger this right over here this
right over here is smaller so the same
numerator the larger the denominator the
smaller the quantity is going to be so
going back to the original question this
is the smaller quantity and this right
over here one-third is the larger
quantity